Today I found out UPS was started by two teenagers
with
one bicycle and $100 borrowed from a friend.
The date was August 28, 1907 and the two kids
were 18 year old Claude Ryan and 19 year old
Jim Casey.
The two had one bike between them and $100
(about $2400 today) borrowed from a friend
to found the “American Messenger Company”
in Seattle, Washington.
The company was initially run in a hotel basement
at Second Avenue and Main Street in Seattle.
At that time, most people didn’t own phones,
so sending telegrams was a frequent thing.
These had to be hand delivered.
In the beginning, the company primarily delivered
these telegrams, but eventually expanded into
transporting pretty much anything that could
be transported on a bicycle or on foot.
Casey and Ryan manned the phone while Casey’s
brother George and a handful of other teenagers
went out making deliveries.
Fast-forward a few years and Casey and Ryan
had merged their company with rival Merchant’s
Parcel Delivery taking the latter’s name.
In the process, they acquired a few motorcycles
and delivery cars with their first car being
a Ford Model T. At this time, more and more
people had telephones so Casey and Ryan switched
to working with retail stores to deliver customers
purchases to their homes.
By the time Casey retired from UPS in 1962,
the company had grown to operating in 31 U.S.
states with annual revenue around $550 million
and about 22,000 workers.
Fast forward to 2013 and Casey and Ryan’s
company that started so humbly is now worth
approximately $80 billion with annual revenue
at over $50 billion; employing just under
half a million workers in 200 countries; delivering
over 3.8 billion packages and documents a
year.
Amazing what $100, some elbow grease, and
a bit of ingenuity can do.